welcome to your mom's house
I want to thank you yesterday the kid
took a dump in his diaper and you were
like I can't tell if this diapers dirty
can you smell it and then you put it
right up to my face and I took like a
deep inhale yeah like like a soulful
yeah
inhale and it was definitely dirty so
thank you yeah you said it was down in
your lungs out it was it was like for a
while to vomit because I kept tasting it
yeah yeah the truth is though I got you
better than then I was actually the
truth is I really didn't I know you're
not gonna believe me and I really wasn't
sure because I didn't get a whiff like I
went to pick him up you know I just
remember I just was like we used some
sniffs on I wish I could say it was as
planned as it was but it wasn't
oh really yeah it really wasn't as as
deliberate no yeah it was real nasty
yeah it's a good smell it was fun though
to watch you said you were like oh my
god you got me good and then an hour
later you were like I feel sick I
inhaled his diaper into my lungs like a
deep whiff